y gaiden 2 en un minuto río anda dando
una vuelta por tokio cuando gracias a un
agente de la cia llamada sonia se entera
de que su clan rival el clan de la araña
negra está atacando su aldea y planea
robar la estatua del demonio para
liberar al archi demonio una criatura
inmensamente poderosa así que a riesgo
se va toda la madre a la aldea en donde
encuentra a su padre yo hayabusa
luchando con el líder del clan de la
araña negra llamado quien sing y ala
demonio de la sangre llamada enlace ver
quien oye con la estatua prepare el río
queda malherido de su pelea y le pide a
su hijo que le haga los mandados y que
recupere la estatua así que río y sonia
viaja por todo el mundo derrotando
muchos enemigos a quien si en grupo de
cuatro poderosos demonios al final de su
viaje es sacerdote infernal de agradar
usa la estatua para resucitar al chamuco
y al río no le queda otra que bajar solo
a puño limpio antes de que el mundo sea
destruido así que luego de una difícil
batalla riu finalmente logra derrotar al
archi demonio y salva así a la humanidad
de nuevo